speed and convenience are driving the
way Canadians are choosing to pay
just pull up my phone and tap it credit
or debit credit 95 of the time and then
debit otherwise but there's one
particular payment option that's
steadily declining cash I can't remember
the last time I had cash on me Canada is
one of the leading countries that's
becoming cashless according to a recent
Global Payments report it's projected
that by 2025 cash will make up only
three percent of all point-of-sale
transactions in the country one of the
lowest in the world with Canadians
opting for more contactless forms of
payment
it's opened the door for new futuristic
shopping experiences
Marie young is one of the co-founders
and Chief Operating Officer of aisle 24.
a cashier-less cashless small format
grocery store in Canada we met up with
her at one of the Toronto locations we
do not accept cash we have never
accepted cash Marie says Canadians are
strapped for time instead of lining up
at the cashier or going through process
of being cashed out you self-serve and
you cash out in off you go meaning ease
and Technology are key the reason why we
accept tap and Mobile Pay is because
that's where the consumer Market is
going we have people coming into our
stores with nothing but their phones or
nothing but their watches because that's
the trend so how does it work you need
to be a member to come in so you
register for an account you've got your
app you press the access button you walk
in shop as you would any other grocery
store or convenience store and you check
out on your own and you leave and
there's nobody there
with this Innovative approach to
in-store shopping Marie says most people
are in and out within five minutes
we built this convenience aspect that
was totally unmanned and driven by
technology the Simplicity of new payment
Technologies are some of the reasons
Canadians are choosing plastic over cash
in fact a report by the Canadian Bankers
Association projects that in the next
five years tap and go payments will
increase by 43 percent
foreign
but what does this shift away from cash
say about our cultural and social
behavior
I don't know if we often pause to think
how strange it is to just pause in the
middle of the street
pay a bill on your phone while
monitoring your Investments these are
both characteristically modern
experiences but also very peculiar in
understanding how this became something
that we think is all right to do Mark
Hayward is an associate professor in the
department of communication and media
studies at York University
he says part of Canada's success of
switching to contactless forms of
payments is that we trust the technology
when the case of cashless banking or
digital banking it was about a much
larger shift in transforming how we
think about our relationship to Banks's
institutions the ways that we trust
computers and Trust digital technology
and the ways that we bring and integrate
those into our daily habits
Mark adds the trust Canadians gained
with cashless banking includes the early
and successful adoption of automated
banking machines
and electronic transaction systems like
interact we have a highly centralized
stable banking sector which means that
at a certain point in time they were
able to cooperate to put in place an
electronic transaction system interact
this meant that Canada was able to make
a tremendous amount of advances in this
particular area through the 1980s that
put it further ahead than the United
States or countries in Europe
and that not only changed how we pay for
items but it also changed our
relationships with technology and each
other
why is it necessary for me to bolt out
of bed at 3 30 in the morning and
forward money to my cousin who I just
bought something from like that's it's
kind of a weird thing so anyway because
you can because you can because this is
now the new Rhythm by which we live with
Finance
but not everyone's jumping on the Casual
bandwagon
we're cash only
Abra Shiner is the owner of the Swan
Dive a proudly cash-only bar in Toronto
cheers we've been cash only since the
beginning we had to start accepting uh I
guess like Square Reader card payments
for a while during the pandemic because
people were so afraid of cash but we got
rid of that about as quickly as we could
it's really inconvenient
accepting only cash is more convenient
for the bar
because it makes the paperwork easier to
do it's quicker to divide tips between
employees and cash actually saves her
money when people want to use a card to
pay with like one of those serious or
debit or Square systems that costs the
business money so every time you go to a
restaurant and pay with your card that
business is losing money
starting in October Canadian businesses
have the option to pass on some of those
credit card fees to customers as a
result of a class action settlement
and what happens if you try to pay with
plastic at Swan Dive
we do have this ATM in the back and
that's when people use it is when they
walk in without cash on them
Abra adds that even though Canadians are
embracing a cashless existence
there's still a lot of businesses that
rely on Cold Hard Cash
the cafe down the street this way
there's still cash only Mama's liquor
and Lounge across the street they're
cash only the barbershop I get my
haircut and as Barbers she's cash only
black dice they're cash only there's a
lot in this community there are a lot of
cash only places
and for some cash equates to a more
equal Society
about this in terms of older users who
don't want to use new technology
we can think about this in terms of
unhoused people who may not have bank
accounts for whom access to digital
Commerce may be very difficult
also about privacy and concerns that
digital purchases can be tracked and
it's not just about buying things
there's another reason Canadians can't
quite kick cash
the other way that we use cash is as a
store of value to save money
cash transactions are declining but
we're increasingly using it as a method
to save
Josh Nye is a senior Economist at RBC in
Toronto his recent report found
Canadians were stashing cash during the
pandemic at the onset of the pandemic
people started hoarding cash some
certain types of cash specifically more
than others tell me about that
phenomenon think back to you know the
Y2K bug toward the end of of the last
century during the global financial
crisis particularly in the U.S where
there were greater concerns about the
solvency of banks you know people were
withdrawing cash ahead of that and of
course during the pandemic in the early
stages in 2020 we saw a real spike in in
cash withdrawals in demand for currency
and turning to banknotes during
tumultuous times perceived or real
offers a sense of security
and it turns out the amount of cash in
circulation is at a 60-year High
a specially larger banknotes like 50s
and 100s it protects against things like
you know cyber vulnerabilities potential
power outages Telecom outages like we
saw this summer you know there's some
some safety that's afforded by by having
you know access to physical physical
cash Global News discovered as a result
of the Rogers outage in July there was a
spike in cash withdrawals do you think
Canada could ever truly become cashless
I think we're still a long way from that
again I would point to this survey
evidence that you know the vast majority
of Canadians have have no plans of going
cashless
and with the future going contactless
some experts say new options are
emerging including micro payment
services
cryptocurrencies or even Central Bank
digital currencies which our Central
Bank is studying
so as we move toward a more digital and
convenient future physical cash has not
lost its appeal
but its role is still unknown in an
increasingly cashless world
people focus on big flashy changes but
this is one of those cases where I
really do think that it's about saying
let's have this debate and this
discussion it is an ethical question it
is a social question
[Music]